nous débutons donc aujourd'hui avec
l'audition de Monsieur tari crime vous
avez été l'un des pionniers de
l'écosystème français du web vous êtes
l'initiateur du mouvement Slow web qui
prône un usage apaisé du numérique et
vous avez fondé plusieurs jeunes pousses
mon net vibes et jolie cloud net vibes
étant une pousse française qui a
beaucoup d'influence et de prescription
et dans la Silicon Valley qui a gagné de
nombreux prix prestigieux et joli Claude
a lancé le joli bouc un ordinateur à
moins de 250 euros développé en France
et utilisant un service d'infos nuage
personnel respectueux de la vie privée
par ailleurs depuis une vingtaine
d'années vous militez pour une véritable
politique de souveraineté numérique en
France si vous intervenez régulièrement
dans les médias en tant que lanceur
d'alerte numérique spécialiste des
questions de géopolitique numérique
d'éthique de militarisation du réseau
pourrait peut-être nous en dire un mot
justement et d'économie numérique vous
avez été enfin vice-président du Conseil
national du numérique où vous avez une
voix vous avez une voix assez singulière
votre expérience votre expertise et vos
prises de position affirmées en faveur
d'une plus grande souveraineté numérique
française et européenne nous intéresse
particulièrement dans le cadre sur le
sujet qui nous occupe aujourd'hui nous
ne savons toujours pas ce qu'est au
juste Tik Tok s'agit-il d'une entreprise
commerciale dans la croissance et le
succès dépasse désormais celui des
autres réseaux sociaux ou est-ce un
outil au service d'un pouvoir à la
recherche d'une plus grande autonomie
numérique dans tous les cas il vous aura
pas échappé que les lignes bougent les
représentants TikTok en Europe disent
désormais s'inscrire dans un dialogue
plus coopératif et que les autorités au
gré des annonces d'interdiction
d'utilisation de l'application qui
ponctuent régulièrement l'actualité
ainsi le projet Clover est annoncé comme
devant permettre une plus grande
sécurisation des données des
utilisateurs européens c'est une annonce
qui soulève quelques questions notamment
celle de l'info nuage souverain je mets
des guillemets européens et de
l'extraterritorialité des droits
américains comme chinois
soulignant malheureusement les
fragilités de notre propre politique de
souveraineté numérique donc on serait
ravi de vous entendre sur l'ensemble de
ces sujets et nous aurons bien
évidemment à commencer par monsieur le
rapporteur un certain nombre de
questions et avant de vous laisser la
parole pour votre exposé liminaire d'une
quinzaine de minutes si vous en êtes
d'accord je dois vous rappeler qu'un
faux témoignage devant la commission est
passible des peines prévues articles 434
13 14 et 15 du code pénal et je vous
invite donc à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure
je vous remercie et nous vous écoutons
ce crime nous sommes ravis de vous
accueillir encore une fois et merci
beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur ce
président d'un monsieur les sénatrices
et sénateurs
donc je vous remercie évidemment pour
cette invitation et je souhaitais vous
dire que je vais intervenir en ayant
principalement trois casquettes la
première en tant qu'entrepreneur qui a
essentiellement développé des produits
qui se sont développés aux États-Unis et
à ce titre je dirais que je suis assez
époustouflé par la performance de Tik
Tok il y a quand même réussi à s'imposer
dans un écosystème extrêmement compliqué
en devenant une des applications voir à
un moment l'application la plus
téléchargée aux États-Unis
la seconde guerre en tant que designer
et product ce qu'on appelle product
designer designer produit spécialisé
dans les questions d'éthique de design
donc évidemment j'ai observé l'évolution
des réseaux sociaux je vais y revenir
mais également la manière dont ces
outils peuvent capter l'attention et
donc toutes ces techniques qui sont
mises en oeuvre et qu'il faut le dire
pour dans le cadre de Tik Tok sont quand
même très très bien mis en oeuvre et
enfin la dernière dans le cadre d'un
film tank je suis en train de lancer sur
les questions de géopolitique à la fois
géopolitique du numérique mais également
sur les nouveaux enjeux de la guerre
notamment ce qu'on appelle la guerre
autonome et notamment à travers l'usage
de l'intelligence artificielle et ce
qu'on appelle en fait
ces nouveaux scénarios de désinformation
synthétique notamment avec l'usage de
l'intelligence artificielle et j'y
reviendrai également
donc en fait mon propos liminaire va se
dérouler en trois parties tout d'abord
soyons honnêtes la grande partie des
choses que l'on reproche à TikTok on
peut les reprocher quasiment à toutes
les applications et je vais revenir sur
la raison pour laquelle on est arrivé
dans cette situation ensuite ce qui est
intéressant c'est que Tik Tok a mis en
place un service assez unique qui crée
une relation très différente avec les
utilisateurs et qui a aussi compris
comment l'écosystème
numérique des réseaux sociaux est devenu
d'une certaine manière toxique qui a su
s'échapper de cette direction enfin il
est pas possible de comprendre ce qu'il
se passe avec Tik Tok notamment vous
avez dû le suivre naturellement le
projet bip partisan de Wall Street Act
aux États-Unis
sans comprendre les enjeux et notamment
la guerre froide technologique entre la
Chine et les États-Unis
faut comprendre les enjeux et les
conséquences mais également pour
l'Europe et pour la France
donc en fait pour comprendre ce qui se
passe dans le monde
de l'Internet il faut retenir une date
assez importante qui est 2010 pourquoi
2010 parce que c'est le moment où en
fait majorité de gens vont commencer à
s'équiper en smartphone
et il y a une différence fondamentale
entre la numérisation qui a eu lieu avec
le smartphone à partir de 2010 et celle
qui a existé un peu avant avec
l'ordinateur je tiens à préciser qu'en
France on a beau eu la chance d'avoir
bien avant ça une autre forme de
numérisation que nous avons connu avec
le militaire on a tendance à l'oublier
mais la population a été massivement
connectée et les services que l'on
trouve sur internet était assez commun
dès les années 80
et donc
ce qui est intéressant c'est que les
réseaux sociaux sont pas si nouveau que
ça essentiellement à partir de 2003 2004
que ces réseaux se mettent en place mais
à l'époque on est dans un environnement
d'ordinateur portable et comme vous le
savez bien quand on regarde ce qu'il
s'est passé finalement et là je
m'appuierais essentiellement sur les
travaux de Jonathan Hyde qui est donc il
y a qui est un chercheur qui a beaucoup
réfléchi à ces questions
ce que l'on voit c'est qu'en fait avec
l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux et de
l'ordinateur portable on est dans une
période très techno utopiste plutôt de
vision progressistes c'est le moment où
on a en fait les printemps arabes c'est
le moment on est au quai by Wall Street
c'est le moment où on pense que
l'Internet en fait un outil qui va
propager la démocratie dans le monde
entier
c'est l'acné en fait de l'air Obama et
de toute l'environnement autour de lui
notamment Google
mais selon et je le cite parce qu'il a
fait les travaux sur des choses que j'ai
toujours
senti de manière intuitive mais n'étant
pas sociologue ce n'est pas mon rôle de
le définir c'est à partir de 2010 que
les choses commencent à se gâter d'une
cérémonie parce que le smartphone est
totalement différent dans son usage
d'une certaine manière l'ordinateur ne
permet pas d'avoir une relation continue
et ultra personnalisée avec que l'on a
avec le mobile typiquement quand je suis
devant mon ordinateur à un moment donné
si je vais à table je me lève et je
laisse l'ordinateur il est déconnecter
alors que son téléphone est souvent avec
soi dans sa poche
et donc d'une certaine manière c'est la
combinaison des réseaux sociaux et du
mobile qui est devenu un cocktail
absolument explosif et qui a eu
principalement deux impacts dont on
commence à peine à comprendre les dégâts
le premier c'est sur la santé mentale
des adolescents et essentiellement
d'ailleurs des adolescentes et la
seconde évidemment
sont nos démocratie
ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est qu'il y
a un autre élément qui a changé avec le
téléphone mobile c'est que ce qu'on
appelait les médias sociaux un terme un
peu qu'on peut pour parler des blogs
c'était des millions d'utilisateurs et
désormais dans le monde des réseaux
sociaux on traite avec des milliards
d'utilisateurs
et ce qui est assez nouveau avec le
téléphone c'est que beaucoup d'entre
nous ont cru que le téléphone était un
espace personnel pour un espace intime
c'est là qu'on met ses photos les plus
intimes que l'on envoie des messages les
plus intimes que l'on a à son agenda
personnel c'est contact personnel
l'ensemble de ces informations
et ce qu'on a pas fait finalement assez
vite compris parce que dans la
régulation on a surtout la régulation
c'est surtout attachée à définir ce que
l'on dit publiquement cet accès à
l'intimité des individus ce que
j'appelle parfois l'intimité
computationnelle c'est à dire que ces
données intimes deviennent de la matière
pour les algorithmes pour nous modéliser
et quelque chose qui a été fait sans
aucune régulation et un moment où en
fait il y avait quasiment aucune limite
il a fallu attendre quelques abus je
crois que c'était aux alentours de 2010
aussi
une société qui s'appelait PAF qui avait
utilisé l'accès à tous les contacts pour
envoyer des messages non désirés pour
qu'Apple décide de mettre des
contraintes c'est-à-dire désormais quand
vous installez une application vous avez
besoin de savoir est-ce que vous lui
donnez accès aux photos ce que vous
donnez accès à vos contacts ce que vous
avez accès à votre localisation donc une
sorte de granularité dans la vie privée
qui n'existait pas auparavant
et encore une fois toujours aussi tendre
il faut lire à ce propos le livre qu'il
a écrit de code lynx of the market mind
ce type de réseau va amplifier à la fois
les micro-agressions
et pour plein de raisons culturelles qui
sont qui sont liées aux États-Unis mais
qui sont aussi un peu le cas en Europe
on
ou les enfants vivent surtout dans les
cocons hyper protégés c'est le moment en
fait on commence à avoir un peu peur de
tout on veut que les enfants restent
dans des environnements apaisés dans les
dans les lycées et ensuite dans les
collèges comme vous le savez on ne veut
pas être exposé à des à des idées ou à
des choses qui sont qui sont pas
forcément celles qu'on pense en fait
tout ça va cette ces réseaux sociaux
vont à la fois augmenter le sentiment de
victimisation l'augmentation de la
passivité une forme d'intolérance aux
idées qui ne sont pas les siennes et
puis aussi une forme de limitation de la
liberté d'expression parce que
finalement il y a plein de choses qu'on
ne veut plus dire parce que si on les
dit on s'expose de fait de la manière
dont les réseaux sociaux sont organisés
à des formes de de trolling et autres et
donc d'une certaine manière et c'est ce
qu'il a très très bien défini c'est que
les réseaux sociaux ce sont d'une
certaine manière opposées dans leur
manière de fonctionner à l'idée d'une
émancipation par l'initiative
individuelle et donc ça de manière on
rentre dans un modèle qui est un modèle
qui est plutôt qui va plutôt à l'inverse
de ce que font les démocraties ou ce que
souhaite être pas dans les démocraties
libérales donc quand une puissance
étrangère voit ce mouvement se faire il
est évident qu'elle n'a pas volonté ou
vocation à le retenir plutôt à
l'amplifier
faut rappeler que ces démarches humaines
le village global qui expliquait que la
vision du monde que l'on a devient
tribal c'est à dire que désormais on vit
dans un monde où on ne croit que ce que
dit s'attribut et tout ce que notre
tribu dit des facto et n'est plus vrai
on avait que le brexit avec les vaccins
enfin les exemples ne manquent pas je
pense que les connaissez tous et ça
s'est traduit par des choses comme une
hausse de la l'anxiété mais
essentiellement d'ailleurs sur les
générations les plus jeunes ce qu'on
appelle la génération Z et notamment
chez les jeunes filles alors j'ai vu
j'avais pris cette
étude qui est qui existait c'est
qu'entre 2010 et 2015 il y a eu un
doublement des cas d'automutilation ce
qu'on appelle salfarm en anglais chez
les jeunes filles donc on sent que les
réseaux sociaux ont eu un impact assez
toxique qu'on a eu énormément de mal à
mesurer puisque aujourd'hui ces études
qui sortent maintenant en 2020 2022 se
base sur les données de 2010-2015 vous
voyez un peu le temps qu'il faut pour
et donc ça c'est un peu le monde qu'on a
construit avec les réseaux sociaux le
monde on a du mal à s'expliquer alors je
passe sur la partie politique parce que
je pense que vous la connaissez
parfaitement et vous la vivez tous les
jours mais ce qui est intéressant et ce
qu'on peut se poser comme question c'est
en quoi Tik Tok se différencie des
autres
et en fait pour résumer les réseaux
sociaux il y a deux types de modèles il
y a ce qu'on appelle les réseaux
d'intérêts par ce qu'on appelle le pas
dans le social graphe donc un graphe
social vous connectez à des gens je vais
y revenir et ce qu'on appelle les graves
d'intérêts les intruscraft alors le
graphe social ça nécessite de suivre des
utilisateurs comme ce tuteur ou de
d'ajouter les gens comme amis donc ça
demande un travail de connexion
donc typiquement le graphe le plus
ouvert c'est cette Twitter et le modèle
le plus connu c'est Facebook mais
historiquement Facebook n'est il faut le
rappeler qu'une cette fortement inspiré
d'un réseau coréen qui s'appelle
sud-coréen pardon qui s'appelait cyword
qui a été le premier à dire nous allons
connecter les gens avec leur véritable
identité
et le problème que quand vous avez un
système de graves c'est que vous avez
besoin très rapidement que les gens
produisent des contenus voilà donc
ce qui est intéressant c'est que il faut
à la fois augmenter le nombre de
connexions il faut être ami ou suivre le
maximum de gens il faut que chacune de
ces connexions produise le plus de
choses je donne toujours cet exemple qui
a été un peu le moment waouh chez
Facebook c'est c'était Marx de garder
qui m'avait raconté ça à l'époque c'est
que les gens changaient leur photo de
profil sur facebook on est en 2004 2005
donc vraiment au tout début et à ce
moment là ils ont eu l'idée de se dire
si on faisait ça un événement
c'est-à-dire je change ma photo de
profil on va la faire la montrer à
l'ensemble des acteurs qui nous suivent
et donc créer des commentaires et donc à
partir de là ils ont découvert que le
réseau social pouvait avoir une forme
d'addiction et donc il fallait renforcer
ces choses alors on a commencé avec les
photos de profil ensuite ça a été les
postes ça a été les photos puis un jour
on a dit on va mettre les liens les
médias et donc on a transformé ce réseau
en un outil
d'accès à absolument toute la formation
était à un moment sur Facebook alors le
problème c'est que
Dan bar donc c'est scientifique a
identifié au delà de 120 150 relations
c'est très difficile de suivre et donc
de toute façon à partir du moment où il
y a énormément de contenu personne ne
peut humainement suivre tout ce que ses
amis ont posé sur facebook donc c'est là
qui évidemment l'algorithme
d'organisation qui s'appelle le Edge
ranch chez Facebook se met en place et
permet d'organiser d'orchestrer pour
chacun d'entre nous son fils d'actu
souvent même à l'avance et donc de
savoir ce que vous allez voir qui est
dans mon différent de ce qu'une autre
personne aurait pu voir
alors
ça a été aussi le cas sur Twitter avec
des situations en fait on crée en
permanence des logiques de chaque
dominance j'ai toujours pour rigoler que
Twitter c'est le seul réseau ou deux
personnes qui ne se connaissent pas ce
Chama et où se dispute au sujet d'un à
propos de quelque chose que je
connaissent pas vraiment et qu'en fait
le système a été construit pour créer
ces entre chocs pour faire que les gens
se se battent alors ce qui a changé avec
Tik Tok c'est qu'en fait ils sont
différenciés je pense qu'ils ont compris
à un moment donné que cette logique
toxique que l'on peut avoir par exemple
avec Instagram où il faut en sans arrêt
montrer le meilleur de soi montrer qu'on
est dans le meilleur hôtel en vacances
que l'on fait les meilleures choses
qu'on est dans les meilleures tout ce
qui a fait qui a créé en fait la
j'avais la culture des influenceurs
c'est quelque chose qui peut être à la
qui peut être sur le long terme à cette
toxique et donc on va décider de choisir
un autre modèle qui est un modèle de
graves d'intérêt le garde intérêt le
principal service qui utilise ça c'est
YouTube et donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
du micro internement vous n'avez plus
besoin de vous dire si vos amis sont
mieux au moins bien que vous vous les
voyez pas vous voyez des vidéos qui
viennent du monde entier et donc ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que
ce type de modèle nécessite
c'est un problème assez simple de en
termes de technologie c'est que
qu'est-ce qu'on va vous proposer quand
vous suivez des amis c'est simple on va
faire une sélection de ce qu'ils ont
fait et on va vous construire et quand
vous allez sur Youtube YouTube doit
évidemment savoir quelle vidéo vous
montrer qu'est-ce que vous aimez quels
sont vos intérêts et donc il y a tout un
travail sur l'algorithmique qui est
complexe parce qu'il faut apprendre donc
une phase d'apprentissage on va d'abord
apprendre ce que vous faites et puis au
fur et à mesure on va essayer de
comprendre ce que vous faites et au fur
et à mesure on espère vous montrer des
vidéos qui vous intéressent alors ça
pose un problème c'est que très souvent
et ça ça a été démontré notamment ça
avait été décrit par la journaliste
senep de c'est qui dans un dans un
article qui avait fait grand bruit à
l'époque
de Trump et de toutes questions de
radicalisation algorithmique
c'est que évidemment les vidéos pour
vous attirer doivent être de plus en
plus engageantes voir elle elle disait
le terme de plus en plus hardcore c'est
à dire qu'elles vont dans des dans des
limites
au-delà de du sentiment j'allais dire de
confort que vous pourriez avoir
et à ce sujet d'ailleurs Guillaume
chasselot qui est maintenant je crois
pérenne a beaucoup travaillé il a été se
lancer de chez YouTube il a beaucoup
travaillé sur les questions
d'algorithmie et lui en saut pourrait
vous en dire un peu plus que moi alors
la force de TiK ToK on dit souvent que
l'algorithme de Tik Tok est meilleur que
celui de YouTube ou de Facebook en fait
ce qui a changé c'est que comme les
vidéos sont beaucoup plus courtes le
temps d'apprentissage est beaucoup plus
court et donc en 50 secondes c'est très
simple quand vous allez sur YouTube dans
l'exemple simple si vous arrêtez une
vidéo sur Youtube d'une heure au bout de
10 minutes est-ce que c'est parce que la
vidéo ne vous plaît pas est-ce que c'est
parce que vous voulez la voir un peu
plus tard
on est en droit de poser la question
vous savez qu'il y a un bouton unlike
mais il est très très peu utilisé alors
que sur Tik Tok dès que votre pouce fait
passer à la vidéo suivante en fait vous
avez dit ça m'intéresse pas et
instantanément tout le flux et
réorganiser alors il y a une autre chose
qui est fascinante c'est que comme
l'espace qui est utilisé et le même donc
on sait toujours les mêmes vidéos c'est
un espace qui est contraint un peu comme
dans une pièce de théâtre et donc on
peut très facilement analyser les photos
l'environnement et donc ça ça permet
d'une certaine manière à cet algorithme
d'aller beaucoup plus loin et je vais
venir par exemple une des choses qui
était très intéressante c'est que
prenons les vidéos de danse qui sont
très populaires vous avez je vous
enverrai j'ai une vidéo qui explique de
Vox qui explique très bien ça c'est très
facile d'analyser les pas les les d'une
vidéo donc d'identifier le type de danse
dont il s'agit et ensuite on va vous
montrer une personne qui est bosvana une
personne qui est à New York une personne
qui est en Corée du Sud qui fait les
mêmes pattes danses d'ailleurs on m'a on
m'a raconté on m'avait confié une
activiste américaine m'avait confié que
pour faire monter des vidéos
sur le l elle elle était défenseur du
changement climatique en fait elles
organisé des des danses en plus des
messages de façon à faire remonter les
les vidéos dans l'algorithme
et donc ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que non seulement avec ces formats
de vidéos on peut les analyser nia est
capable d'analyser de retrouver des
vidéos similaires dans un des millions
de vidéos des milliards de vidéos mais
on n'est pas si loin qu'on voyait les
technologies génératives comme
mitchornay ou même j'ai pété dans la
plus connue mais il y a des par exemple
une société qui s'appelle runway ml qui
permet aujourd'hui de faire une vidéo de
6 à 10 secondes à partir d'un simple
texte on est plus très loin demain
d'avoir un des contenus totalement
synthétiques en utilisant non seulement
les requêtes d'un être humain qui
n'aurait qu'à taper ce qu'il souhaite
mais en utilisant l'algorithmie
c'est-à-dire toutes les toutes les
archives de base de données sur les
dents sur les musiques sur la façon les
vidéos sont faites vous avez un
catalogue absolument énorme
algorithmiquement accessible et qui
pourrait reconstruire à l'infini des
vidéos donc on est pas très loin de ce
de ce modèle et qui est un modèle qui
pourrait également poser des questions
puisque dès lors que vous avez des
influenceurs ça reste des êtres humains
mais vous pouvez construire vous pourrez
construire des influenceurs totalement
artificielles qui sont contrôlés en
fonction de données qui peuvent être
également des données algorithmiques
donc on rentre dans une aire totalement
nouvelle
alors
de conclure
bien sûr alors très rapidement la
question qu'on pose souvent la Tic-Toc
c'est la question évidemment de la Chine
mais également la question de la guerre
technologique entre la Chine et
un pardon André la Chine Etats-Unis
alors faut rappeler une chose c'est que
la Chine se connecte à internet en 94 3
ans plus tard se déconnecte et au fur et
à mesure elle va empêcher l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux de fonctionner sur son
territoire ce qu'on appelle le
splinternet alors il y a eu des bras de
fer très intéressants entre la Chine et
le salut je vous en donner simplement
deux
il y a quelques années je crois qu'en
2019 c'est un
entraîneur de la NBA qui a adressé sur
Twitter réseau américain en anglais aux
Américains donc je rappelle que Twitter
n'est pas accessible en Chine un message
sympathique je crois que c'était à Hong
Kong à l'époque des manifestations à
partir de là la Chine a menacé la NBA
qui a demandé si on s'est bien compris
ce qui a été dit à cet entraîneur de
présenter des excuses il y a eu
semble-t-il aussi un boycott de son
équipe qui était le Houston Rocket en
Chine donc on s'est trouvé dans un
premier cas où en fait
d'habitude il y avait un contrôle très
fort à l'intérieur de la Chine sur tout
ce qui vient de l'Occident et désormais
un système où les valeurs en tout cas la
vision chinoise pouvait s'exporter sur
des réseaux
alors l'autre chose c'est que cette
guerre technologique elle a lieu pour
une raison simple alors elle a commencé
avec Obama avec Trump elle est sortie
l'ambiguïté avec baiden on est rentré
vraiment dans le dur c'est tout
simplement d'empêcher la Chine
d'exporter des produits à forte valeur
ajoutée
quels sont-ils la 5G donc les
interdictions Huawei GTE TikTok TikTok
c'était 4 milliards de dollars l'année
dernière c'était 12 milliards de dollars
donc ça devient Besson conséquente
probablement beaucoup plus cette année
on aura les on aura les chiffres plus
tard et donc cette idée de d'empêcher la
Chine de d'une certaine manière d'avoir
accès aux dernières technologies des
technologies qui sont américaines des
logiciels
l'intelligence artificielle mais qui
sont aussi européenne faut-il le
rappeler toutes les puces de nos
téléphones sont en fait basés sur une
société qui s'appelle arm qui est une
société anglaise dont toute la propriété
intellectuelle est basée en Hollande et
la lithographie pour construire ses
puces de dernière génération est en fait
basé en Hollande c'est ce style
s'appelle ASML qui est en fait une la
continuité de Philips et donc il y a
tout un débat sur doit-on donner à la
Chine ou pas l'accès à cette technologie
Biden a tranché il a dit que plus aucune
de ces technologies n'est accessible et
plus aucun des acteurs américains ne
peut travailler sur ces technologies
donc en fait au cœur de ça au-delà de la
question de la question de l'influence
il y a cette question d'empêcher la
Chine de pouvoir exporter des produits à
très fortes à ajouter
conclusion je vous proposerai juste
trois questions par rapport à la réponse
que pensait Tik Tok en fait il y a trois
points de vue il y a le point de vue de
la santé publique si c'est un vrai
problème que fait-on et que fait-on en
fait pour règlementer l'accès l'intimité
des gens ça c'est vrai pour Tik Tok mais
c'est vrai pour tout le monde d'un point
de vue politique c'est un sujet aussi de
média que dirait-on si Fox si bien ou
TF1 était contrôlé par un acteur chinois
que dirait-on d'ailleurs si Tik Tok
c'était contrôlé par un acteur qatari ou
iranien quel serait notre relation à ce
genre de produit et puis enfin il y a la
question économique et la réciprocité
Tik Tok a la possibilité de générer plus
de 12 milliards de dollars de revenus
dans le monde occidental l'inverse n'est
évidemment pas vrai puisque aucun des
acteurs sur les start-up françaises ou
américaines ne peuvent générer de
revenus là-bas voilà je suis désolé
d'avoir été un peu long
merci beaucoup je vous propose qu'on
passe directement aux questions de
monsieur le rapporteur et puis que les
uns les autres se signalent s'ils ont
des questions
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup pour cette
exploser introductif qui est bien que
court était
particulièrement riche et qui évidemment
nous amène un certain nombre de
questions
la première question concerne le sujet
que vous avez évoqué de la granularité
des informations
c'est à dire l'accès aux données privées
[Musique]
ils on nous dit un certain nombre des
personnes qui ont été auditionnées nous
disent d'une part que le nombre de
fonction le nombre de données le nombre
de fonctions du smartphone
auquel TikTok l'application demande à
avoir accès pour pouvoir la télécharger
de façon complète et
est infiniment plus nombreux ce nom est
infiniment plus important que dans celui
des autres plateformes
que Youtube Facebook etc
ma question c'est celle-là est-ce que
vous confirmez cela et deuxièmement
est-ce que la désactivation ou le refus
de ces de la livraison de ces données de
ces fonctions
empêchent de charger l'application et
troisièmement j'ai peut-être le plus
important
dans ma question est-ce que vous avez
une idée du pourcentage de Jean et
notamment d'adolescents et de jeunes
puisque même si ça change récemment
c'est quand même un public très jeune
est-ce que vous avez
une idée du pourcentage de ce qui accède
à cette désactivation désactivation moi
mon sentiment c'est qu'il y en a pas un
pour 1000 et que tout le monde laisse
comme sur les autres applications
d'ailleurs mais comme c'est une
application qui en demande beaucoup plus
voilà c'est le premier problème de cette
granularité est-ce qu'il y a de ce point
de vue là une différence entre Tik Tok
et les autres dans le nombre de choses
demandées et dans les difficultés ou les
facilités de la désactivation
évidemment vous comprenez pourquoi je
pose la question c'est la question des
données personnelles et la question de
la vie privée
bien pour répondre à la question de la
granularité des données non je me suis
pour le bien de cette audition remis à
installer Tik Tok sur mon téléphone
et mon sentiment c'est que je compte je
regarde les permissions qui sont
demandées par une saucisse par Facebook
et celle qui sont demandées par TikTok
les permissions demandées par Tik Tok
sont bien moindres en fait il n'y a plus
accès aux photos plus accès à l'agenda
alors ça ne veut pas dire pour autant
que la capacité de pister au tracan
utilisateur
n'existe pas mais d'un point de vue de
la collecte des données privées le
sentiment que Tik Tok a d'une certaine
manière
baisser cette collecte en tout cas sur
le téléphone
et je dirais pour deux raisons la
première c'est que
je ne pense pas que ce soit très
important pour leur modèle aujourd'hui
Tik Tok et véritablement dans une
logique de micro voire nano
Entertainment donc c'est un une sorte de
Netflix d'ailleurs il y a une enquête
aux États-Unis qui a qui semblait dire
que les adolescents préfèrent garder Tik
Tok que qu'un abonnement à l'ensemble
des services de streaming aux États-Unis
ce qu'il faut beaucoup de questions
et que d'une certaine manière je pense
que c'est un des sujets dont on ne parle
assez peu c'est qu'on se focalise
souvent sur les données privées c'était
la collecte de données sur votre
téléphone qui sont ensuite dupliqués
dans le Cloud de ces plateformes soit
pour être utilisé soit très souvent
quand on accède à votre carnet d'adresse
c'est pour savoir qui sont les gens que
vous connaissez qui sont déjà sur le
service et qui vont donc automatiquement
recevoir une demande de façon à
fluidifier l'accès
et ce qu'on oublie c'est qu'une des
grandes valeurs d'un produit c'est comme
Tik Tok c'est la valeur d'usage plus
vous utilisez le produit plus la
connaissance de ce que l'on va vous
proposer indépendamment de qui vous êtes
on n'a pas besoin de connaître votre nom
on n'a pas besoin de savoir vous habitez
de façon toute application c'est vous
habitez puisque c'est l'endroit où le
téléphone est posé de 8h du soir à 8h du
matin donc cette information est déjà
connue on n'a pas besoin de l'avoir et
donc on est véritablement dans une
logique d'amélioration de la
connaissance donc c'est un point de vue
de l'individu et de cette amélioration
de la connaissance et des usages de
l'amélioration de l'algorithme global
donc en fait les obsessions de ces
entreprises c'est d'intégrer des
systèmes qui sont fluides pour pouvoir
intégrer de la publicité de manière
quasi-métronomique
toutes les X vidéos alors ça dépend des
services
donc ça c'est la première question alors
concernant les choses comme les messages
de ce qu'on appelle les darwick message
donc les messages privés que l'on peut
envoyer avec ces applications mais c'est
vrai aussi avec Twitter avec facebook
évidemment ces entreprises en ont
techniquement la capacité d'y accéder à
ce qu'elle le font ça je me risquerais
pas à l'affirmer alors sur la question
la désactivation ce que vous posez qui
est très intéressante parce que c'est
une question qui avait été posée à Mark
Zuckerberg lors d'une une question au
Sénat américain donc lors de son
audition
et une des questions qu'on se pose
souvent c'est que Tik Tok fonctionne
avec l'application donc une fois que
vous l'enlevez a priori elle n'a plus
d'accès en tout cas ça c'est une
question qu'on ne pose pas qu'on ne peut
pas poser à Tik Tok c'est plutôt une
question qu'il faudrait poser Apple
puisque c'est eux qui ont le contrôle du
système d'exploitation Apple ou Google
mais quand vous allez sur le web
évidemment c'est c'est ces services
déposent des cookies
et donc très souvent on a ce qu'on
appelle des profils fantômes c'est à
dire que tous les gens par exemple tu
utilises Facebook alors ça je peux
parler de Facebook parce que on a parlé
publiquement lors de l'édition du Sénat
je pense que ça doit être similaire avec
avec Tik Tok mais je n'en ai pas là
l'assurance quand vous n'avez pas de
connexion avec facebook on crée un
profil fantôme et ce profil fantôme donc
ça veut dire qu'on met un pixel sur
votre sur votre téléphone qui vous
traque et à un moment donné on sera
capable de savoir si ce pixel pour
l'instant vous êtes une personne anonyme
vous devenez une personne
identifiée lorsque vous vous reconnectez
à Facebook mais si vous ne vous
connectez pas ou si vous ne vous
connectez jamais à Facebook ce profil
fantôme existe et donc est traité comme
un individu donc vous n'avez pas
d'identité mais le profil peut d'une
certaine manière accéder à vous suivre
et donc
continuer à vous à vous traiter
donc la question qui se pose c'est
comment peut-on désactiver ces profils
fantômes a priori le seul moyen de le
faire c'est d'effacer ses cookies mais
comme vous le savez le téléphone
désormais possède des
identifiants uniques
et donc il est possible que même on est
face à ces cookies je dis possible
de pouvoir
continuer à avoir cette information
alors sur la question de la de la
désactivation moi je pense que tous ces
services en fait vont ce qu'on appelle
en bon en français un customer cycle
donc un cycle de consommateur où on doit
très vite amener une personne sur un
produit la rendre addict ensuite une
fois qu'elle a été bien profilée c'est
le moment elle devient la plus rentable
et au cas où elle décide de quitter il y
a tout un ensemble de d'éléments soit le
fait que leurs amis leur liste t'as pas
vu la dernière vidéo sur TikTok tu as
pas vu ça dans toute une pression
sociale qui existe pour vous ramener sur
le produit et donc à partir de là on
recommence le cycle et donc toutes ces
sociétés de réseaux sociaux mais en fait
toutes les sociétés Internet ont une
gestion de ce qu'on appelle le turn donc
le nombre de gens qui quittent et à
chaque fois on essaye de trouver toutes
les techniques possibles et imaginables
pour les faire revenir dans le jeu et en
général ça marche plutôt bien parce que
alors je ne sais pas dans le cadre de
Tik Tok mais pour Facebook quand vous
déconnectez Facebook vous des mails qui
sont un peu bizarres parfois en vous
disant ah telle personne a posté telle
chose donc ça aiguise votre curiosité
évidemment vous avez envie de revenir
depuis un moment donné vous finissez par
revenir parce qu'il y aura un message
qui a telle personne j'aime bien cette
personne je veux absolument savoir ce
qu'elle a dit et donc on se reconnecte
donc il y a tout un tout un travail qui
est mis en place mais voilà c'est tout
ce que je peux vous dire là-dessus
merci beaucoup
une deuxième question vous avez tout à
l'heure dit parmi les
préoccupations des Américains puisque
évidemment les plateformes les
principales plateformes sont américaines
principales
américains c'est
l'exportation des données
à forte valeur ajoutée une exportation
partie toc donnait forte valeur ajoutée
ce qui n'est pas possible pour les
sociétés américaines et c'est donc un
problème économique important mais
au-delà du problème économique il y a un
deuxième problème
[Musique]
on va pas parler et qui semble être un
des sujets réels ou pas ou
ou à léguer mais qui semble tout de même
pour partir réel des Américains qui
consistent à l'inverse dans
l'importation par Tik Tok et par ces
sociétés Merbes c'est par le Parti
communiste et sa cellule etc de donner à
forte valeur ajoutée qui sont les
données démographiques enfin à partir de
tout ce qu'on peut recueillir sur à la
fois sur les les
attitudes des des internautes et à la
fois sur ce qui est accessible dans leur
téléphone
c'est important aujourd'hui
elle semble
[Musique]
à partir tant que l'application Texas et
l'affiliation Clover en Europe ne sont
pas mises en place elle semble permise
pratiquement à limite donc est-ce que
vous confirmez cela et deuxièmement
ce qui aux États-Unis s'opposent au
projet Texas nous disent Oracle aura
beau mettre dans le sens de
l'application sur les serveurs et il y
aura toujours des portes dérobées et ça
ne on n'arrivera pas à le à l'empêcher
c'est la même chose pour le Texas et
pour les États-Unis ça nous concerne
moins mais c'est la même chose pour le
projet Clover qui n'est pas et
d'ailleurs qui est dans une grande
opacité tout à l'heure Michael Valley en
commençant à dire employé une phrase
mais un peu plus exactement laquelle
mais qui consiste à dire c'est très très
difficile de voir ce qui se passe
depuis le début de ces auditions le mot
qui revient dans ma dans ma tête quand
j'entends un peu ce que tous les uns et
les autres nous disent c'est l'opacité
c'est le caractère vraiment compliqué
toujours bien entendu de l'ensemble des
plateformes mais encore plus sur des
clubs que sur les autres
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a un
moyen à travers le projet des classes ou
à travers le projet Clover d'avoir la
certes d'arrivée à la certitude qu'il
n'y ait pas de porte de ruée donc
d'exploitation des données qui remontent
à Singapour impeccin et vos parties
communistes chinois le cas échéant ou
est-ce que c'est une purfiction et c'est
totalement
impossible et si c'est possible
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'est-ce qu'il
faut exiger
par rapport au projet Clover
effectivement c'est des questions
pertinentes alors je ne suis pas certain
je n'ai aucune information privilégiée
sur le sujet je comme vous je m'informe
je lis je me documente et de temps en
temps je me laisse aller à quelques
scénarios
mais mais tout d'abord ce qui est ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que
encore une fois alors
à travers ce que vous avez dit il y a
plusieurs questions la première c'est
celle de l'extraat territorialité du
droit certaine manière et des politiques
je me permettrais de dire que tout
touriste chinois qui vient avec son
téléphone à Paris qui prend des photos
de notre dame ou plutôt de la Tour
Eiffel
toute personne qui est photographiée
d'une certaine manière se retrouver
intégrer
dans le Crédit Social chinois en tout
cas si les techniques
d'automatisation des visages de scanning
des visages existent donc d'une des
facto
il y a il n'y a pas de il y a une forme
de porosité vis-à-vis de tout ça
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que effectivement
ce que vous avez noté remarqué qui me
semble important et qui est d'ailleurs
vrai pour tous les réseaux sociaux c'est
qu'on est dans une situation qui est
plutôt anormale dans la mesure où
l'ensemble des plateformes chinoises ont
la capacité de monétiser d'accéder à
l'ensemble des données on parle souvent
des réseaux sociaux mais vous avez ce
qu'on appelle les Data brokers qui vous
permet d'avoir accès à quasiment toutes
les informations
de tous les consommateurs américains
pour appris d'ailleurs il y a eu un
modèle un scandale parce que je crois
que le FBI c'était qui avait besoin
d'informations acheter de manière légale
les informations commerciales et sont
nécessaires vie donc ça c'est accessible
à tout le monde il y a aucune véritable
interdiction
et puis par contre l'inverse est
beaucoup plus complexe impossible
puisque effectivement
au niveau des firewall mais également au
niveau des
des droits et de voir des acteurs en
Chine j'appelle alors on n'a jamais su
ce qui s'est véritablement passé mais
une des raisons pour laquelle Google a
quitté
la Chine c'est qu'on il semblerait que
que son code source une partie de code
source aurait été visité
donc ce qui peut-être explique aussi
parce que comme vous le savez Eric
Schmitt était en désormais en charge ou
en tout cas et la personne qui la plus
la plus
hostile à une idée de donner à des
avantages à la Chine dans le domaine
numérique et c'est peut-être lié à son
expérience c'est une expérience
personnelle et donc on se retrouve avec
plusieurs questions effectivement la
question de l'extra territorialité du
droit c'est à dire que des facto est-ce
que le droit chinois s'applique
en Europe et aux États-Unis
la réponse c'est probablement oui ça a
été exploit confirmé ça vous a été
confirmé je crois pas par la CNIL
quelle est la contrepartie de tout ça
elle est plutôt faible
et par rapport à la question de savoir
si un acteur donc dès lors qu'il
s'intégrer si je comprends bien le
problème le projet Clover et le projet
le projet Texas c'est de dire que les
Data Center de ces entreprises seront
aux États-Unis
mais quel que soit la localisation d'un
Center si vous n'avez pas accès au code
source s'il n'y a pas de dite toute
personne
travaillant pour la compagnie peut avoir
accès à tel ou tel bonnet
ça pose des questions de sécurité ça
pose des questions évidemment
donc quand vous êtes citoyen américain
aux États-Unis
si vous avez des risques pénaux vous
allez réfléchir à deux fois mais quand
vous n'êtes pas citoyen américain et que
ou européen et que l'opération se
faisait aux États-Unis en Europe
évidemment la question
se posera différemment donc pour
répondre à cette question c'est que
techniquement
beaucoup de choses sont possibles la
question qui se pose et c'est une
question à mon avis qui se pose pour
l'Europe aussi puisqu'on a on a le rgpd
on a l'ensemble de lois qui protègent la
vie privée en plus de celle qui existe
aux États-Unis c'est de savoir
effectivement quels seront
quelle manière l'intimité des
utilisateurs va être traitée et puis
surtout la façon dont les flux de
données
vis-à-vis de la de la de la Chine vont
être traités là effectivement ça devient
une discussion extrêmement technique et
ça demande à nos outils techniques et je
ne sais pas si aujourd'hui dans le cadre
de ces projets ce type de livre en tout
cas aux États-Unis rien à filtrer et les
techniques tout est possible d'un point
de vue légal on peut mettre des
contraintes mais à partir de là c'est la
technique l'emporte sur le légal
effectivement on peut se poser des
questions
pour prolonger ma question d'une façon
plus générale
est-ce que vous pensez que les
on va être concernés très très vite
puisqu'on va en avoir l'application en
France et je Senna et l'Assemblée
nationale pour être concernés est-ce que
vous pensez que les directives contenus
dans les DMA et le DSA
sont aujourd'hui
une réponse
rgpd puis DMA PDSA sont aujourd'hui une
réponse
complète et
satisfaisante aux problèmes posés par
les questions de vie privée sur les
plateformes en général et sur Tik Tok en
particulier et deuxièmement est-ce que
vous pensez au cas où elles sont
suffisantes que aujourd'hui l'Europe les
pays européens et notamment la France
dispose je pense que ce sera mutualisé
mais dispose des capacités techniques et
surtout humaines nécessaires
en nombre de pas en qualité mais en
nombre de techniciens pour pouvoir les
faire respecter où est-ce qu'il y a un
sujet par rapport au DMA et DSA
je crains c'est que le rgpd sur le
papier est une très bonne idée
m'éclat résultante de ce de cette loi
pour le consommateur ce sont des pop-up
absolument partout donc on a
pas finalement travaillé de manière
globale c'est-à-dire qu'on a on avait
une idée qui est forte
une idée d'ailleurs qui nous différencie
des États-Unis sur la façon dont on
pense est traite la vie privée
mais que dans son application on aurait
dû réfléchir également au design de la
manière dont ces produits doivent se
faire
et le problème du DMA et du DSA c'est
qu'ils sont votés au moment où d'une
certaine manière le sujet change de
au départ on parle de la toxicité des
plateformes et entre temps lia
générative vient de s'intégrer tout
c'est tous ces problèmes vont être plus
ou moins communs et d'une certaine
manière on a on s'intéresse
essentiellement et on pourrait parler du
Yama dassam mais également de Léa Act
c'est qu'on s'intéresse aux conséquences
et très rarement en cause c'est-à-dire
qu'on explique aux entreprises voilà ce
que vous devez nous nous faire voilà ce
que la manière dont le service doit
fonctionner vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
mais on oublie les la manière dont on va
construire notamment l'accès à
l'intimité des utilisateurs la manière
dont on va transformer
je dis souvent que quand les réseaux
sociaux ont transformé les gens en pâte
à modeler on peut les mettre dans
n'importe quel moule et c'est un peu ce
qu'on a fait aux États-Unis ce qu'on est
en train de faire en Europe et on a
assez peu travaillé sur l'amont
et de la même manière que quand on sort
un produit médical vous savez bien il y
a tout un travail qui sont faits sur les
effets secondaires il y a quand même un
travail d'études un peu conséquent
aujourd'hui on laisse des produits qui
sont des boîtes noires
s'intégrer dans l'intimité des gens sans
aucun seul aucune analyse d'impact
sociétal social alors j'allais vous dire
on va voir la même question avec lia
générative et la désinformation un
nouveau un niveau d'échelle largement
plus important mais à chaque fois on
oublie que
une des raisons pour lesquelles on parle
de santé mentale de santé démocratique
c'est qu'elles sont liées si les gens
sont mal dans leur peau à cause des
réseaux sociaux il y a pas de raison que
leur vision politique ou leur vision de
la politique soit soudain bien meilleur
donc il y a une connexion entre les deux
et d'une certaine manière on a il y a
pas de garde-fou c'est-à-dire qu'on a pu
laisser des gens emprisonnés on parlait
de cette jeune Anglaise qui a vu le
un des services de réseaux sociaux lui
parler de suicide pendant des semaines
avant qu'elle donc il y a très peu de
réglementations parce qu'on est aussi et
les réseaux sociaux sont bloqués parce
qu'on est dans une question de le volume
on gère des volumes tellement importants
parlent de milliards de gens dans le cas
de Facebook et que la seule solution
possible c'est les algorithmes avec
cette question qui est toujours la même
c'est qu'on vous dit oui effectivement
il y a eu des problèmes dans tel ou tel
pays alors
de la Birmanie à
à l'Inde enfin quasiment tous les pays
ont des problèmes mais ne vous inquiétez
pas la prochaine génération d'algorithme
ce sera meilleur et donc on a en fait un
problème qui est très simple c'est que
la manière c'est c'est plateformes
fonctionnent c'est que d'abord vous avez
les gens qui font du produit donc il
faut un produit qui soit le plus
addictif ensuite vous avez la
monétisation donc c'est la deuxième
équipe il faut le produit qui monétise
le mieux possible et puis ensuite vous
avez tout ce qui est
la gestion des problèmes on a il y a un
terme interne qui est utilisé souvent
qui va me revenir excusez moi j'ai un
trou sur la gestion de des potentiels
effets de bord ça ça vient en troisième
et comme vous savez que les ingénieurs
sont leurs bonus et payés sur leur
capacité à faire que le produit soit le
plus addictif croise le plus vite ils ne
vont faire que ça quand l'équipe de
monétisation leur bonus ne sont pensés
que sur la monétisation ils ne vont
faire que ça et c'est normal et ensuite
quand vous avez la régulation qui vient
après elle vient après les autres et
donc il y a un désalignements entre les
intérêts et dans tous les services ont
été pensés d'abord pour la croissance
puis pour la méditation et puis les
problèmes sociétaux viennent après et
donc il faudrait que ces lois obligent
une certaine manière à repenser d'une
façon différente la conception même de
ces produits et ça pose un vrai sujet on
a su le faire dans le domaine médical
avec la bioéthique dans plein de
domaines mais c'est vrai que dans le
domaine de la technologie pour une
certaine manière peut-être parce qu'on a
on a du mal à comprendre comment c'est
ces choses fonctionnent et très souvent
certains services eux-mêmes n'ont pas
compris
la manière dont ça fonctionne on a cette
incapacité à à
vouloir réglementer en amont et je pense
que c'est la chose qui doit être la plus
importante merci j'ai eu beaucoup de
questions mais je vais arrêter là parce
que je vois que nos collègues les
questions au gouvernement à 15h j'ai
peur que après obligé de
merci d'avoir évoqué les textes de
règlement européen en cours certains ont
été votés d'autres sont encore en cours
de débat au sein du trilogue je pense
aussi au data actes qui suit le
règlement il y a tout ça fonctionne
ensemble même si les textes sont
déconnectés les uns des autres il y a
une logique qui les rendent à ces textes
et de ce que je vous dis je crois
comprendre de qu'il y a une insuffisance
par rapport au texte actuellement
proposé ce qui rejoint le travail de
notre commission des affaires
européennes qui a travaillé cette
question entre guillemets par des mois
d'anxiété du safety by design comment
avant de mettre sur le marché une
application
qui fonctionne avec des algorithmes
quand il y a une révision
des fonctionnements d'une plateforme
d'une application comment on revoit
aussi la copie et on oblige à cette
démarche
d'expérimentation et si
l'expérimentation prouve qu'il y a des
effets extrêmement pervers ou toxiques
c'est bien on met pas sur le sur le
marché ça c'est les propositions que
nous nous avons fait à la commission des
affaires européennes tant sur le DSA que
sur
il y a donc vous confortez bien l'idée
que actuellement c'était par rapport aux
problématiques qu'on observe soulevées
par TikTok ne sont pas assez protecteur
notamment des des jeunes ça c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
porte sur la guerre froide
entre les États-Unis et la Chine sur
lequel vous avez beaucoup insisté et
j'ai noté une première phrase aussi vous
avez dit que somme toute TikTok un peu
de différence près
à les mêmes effets négatifs que les
autres plateformes en tout cas tous les
défauts on les retrouve sur les autres
plateformes est-ce à dire que finalement
nous Européens on devrait assez
équidistants entre les deux les deux
pays où il te continent en guerre
technologique et finalement on portait
la même exigence vous observez malgré
tout ce que nous cherchons à savoir au
sein de cette commission d'enquête avec
notre rapporteur si le cas de la
plateforme chinoise est beaucoup plus
toxique et dangereuse qui a justifié
d'ailleurs des interdictions notamment
aux États-Unis où faut-il y voir
finalement
somme toute une stratégie des États-Unis
pour ne pas se laisser dépasser comme à
l'instar d'un Elon Musk qui dit faut un
moratoire sur sur l'IA parce que en
réalité
c'est pas c'est pas aussi comment
dirais-je dénué d'intérêt que ça il est
lui-même en concurrence avec openia et
le producteur de Betty voilà pouvez-vous
nous dire précisément si on doit porter
une attention particulière à la
plateforme chinoise alors déjà peut-être
en guise d'introduction et puis pour
pour bien clarifier mon propos il est
évident que entre les États-Unis et la
Chine il y a aucune
moi c'est évident que les États-Unis
sont une démocratie que d'ailleurs le
Congrès et le Sénat américain sont
plutôt actifs sur ces questions on a
donc le cas de la Chine est évidemment
un cas un cas par qui est à la fois à
mon avis
qui propose deux formes qui a deux
formes de danger la première c'est
effectivement que d'une certaine manière
cette plateforme
ultra addictive à mon avis quand même
beaucoup plus addictif que les autres
et qui a comme effet d'ailleurs de faire
que désormais et YouTube et pardon
facebook propose des systèmes possibles
donc en fait on a un nivellement par le
bas
j'avais dire presque au niveau du
caniveau en termes de de puissance
développée sur ces sur ces technologies
donc ça c'est la première chose
effectivement la deuxième c'est que
c'est un outil
d'influence
à minima un outil qui qui rend passif
les populations occidentales
c'est-à-dire qu'on a une génération qui
a désormais une capacité d'attention
très faible moi j'ai moi je me rappelle
je fais partie d'une génération qui se
rappelle quand on a eu de la vous savez
quand on l'a coupé les émissions avec la
publicité on trouvait ça insupportable
et on parlait de 15000 voire 15-20
minutes je crois si je me rappelle bien
et donc aujourd'hui on est effectivement
dans un monde où les interruptions sont
toutes les 50 secondes on est on est
plus très loin d'un poisson rouge d'une
certaine manière et donc effectivement
ça pose une question parce que comme
vous le savez bien en Chine ou les lois
sur les réseaux sociaux sont très fortes
et les lois sur l'intelligence
artificielle sont également très fortes
il y a une forme de
dureté du gouvernement sur ces questions
donc que nous n'avons pas et et
nous a la manière elle profite en fait
de ce laisser aller du fait que sur la
question de la notamment quand vous avez
entre 13 et 16 ans la constitution de
votre
exactement je crois que vous avez
quelqu'un qui est venu en parler c'est
c'est vraiment très inquiétant de se
dire que au moment où vous avez le moins
confiance en vous en fait on va
travailler algorithme à vous détruire
cette conférence c'était le cas avec
Instagram dans une logique sociale ou en
fait telle personne était voilà il
fallait être en permanence en
compétition et avec Tik Tok dans une
logique on se ramollit de sa manière
c'est-à-dire qu'on se désintéresse des
choses parce que finalement dès qu'il y
a un problème on se remet dans C'est un
peu la stratégie de l'autruche on se
remet dans un dans un système qui nous
fait échapper la réalité et donc
effectivement il y a des conséquences
politiques sociales qu'on a
pas encore bien étudié qui
mais on a déjà 10-15 ans maintenant
d'expérience donc c'est pour ça que à
mon avis sur le dmlds pour revenir
là-dessus moi je suis favorable et dans
la régulation mais j'ai envie d'une
régulation je devrais faire une
régulation qui soit moindre qui soit
moins volumineuses mais qui aille au
fond du problème qui aille de bout en
bout quand je mettrai en fait des
différents textes qui est d'une certaine
manière créer une forme de bureaucratie
dans le développement des applications
et qui ne s'intéresse pas aux vrais
problèmes qui sont véritablement la
conception de ces applications quand on
conçoit une app et qu'elle va être mise
dans les mains de millions de personnes
imaginez remplacer le mot app par
médicament vous savez tout de suite
qu'on est plus du tout dans la même
conversation même une publicité à la
télé si vous si vous avez faites une
publicité mensongère vous vous pouvez
être attaqué donc il y a tout un travail
qu'on a fait qui ont qui fait que
soudainement le développement d'apprent
échappe d'une certaine manière à toute
réglementation on réglemente une fois
que l'application a été mise sur le
marché et qu'elle a créé des dommages
je sais pas si j'ai répondu à vos spé
je pense que Tik Tok a dans la logique
de la course à LAF à la je dirais à la
tension Tik Tok a été un peu plus loin
que les autres en allant
alors il faut il faut aussi comprendre
que que Facebook a un historique c'est
au départ un réseau sociaux un réseau
social pardon dans les pour les
universités qui ensuite devenu le réseau
social de l'ensemble de l'humanité qui
ensuite devenu un espèce de d'hybride
entre sites de news d'infos avec
plusieurs équipes qui fonctionnent pas
toujours très bien entre elles donc ils
n'ont pas forcément les mêmes objectifs
Tik Tok a été pensé pour créer de
l'addiction instantanée et AP des heures
d'attention par jour des zones attention
qui ne sont plus accessibles à la
télévision aux autres sources
d'informations parce qu'on nous dit
souvent que Tik Tok est un outil
d'information mais quand vous regardez
plus la télé vous ne lisez plus la
presse vous n'écoutez plus la radio vous
ne lisez plus les sites Web ou très peu
vous n'avez qu'un résumé en 50 secondes
de l'actualité c'est aussi un outil qui
a une vocation
à ce niveau là et donc à mon avis les
c'est ils ont été un peu plus loin que
les autres dans ce dans ce domaine et
parce qu'ils ont été un peu plus loin
que c'est très rentable évidemment tout
le monde veut aller dans la même
direction et donc ça présage quand même
un futur assez assez complexe
question de politique fiction
c'est un peu la question du
de la machine qui échappe à son à son
maître la question de l'apprenti sorcier
aujourd'hui aux États-Unis vous l'avez
sans doute suivi
l'audition de du CIO de
au Congrès c'est assez mal passé c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire et vous l'avez
évoqué d'ailleurs un travail
transpartisan de
du congrès de et du Sénat
qui vise en tout cas c'est une
probabilité assez forte à l'interdiction
pure et simple d'ailleurs le Montana un
des États-Unis a déjà interdit
d'application non seulement sur ses
fonctionnaires comme beaucoup de pays
européens et américains mais pour
l'ensemble de la population
ce qui pose d'ailleurs le problème ça
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour faire
respecter ça au Montana si c'est pas
respecté ailleurs mais bon en tout cas
on peut se diriger vers ça les médias
semble dire que bayden hésite beaucoup
parce qu'il pense que le jour où il
supprime cette application qui est
téléchargée par 150 milliards
d'Américains ça risque de les poser des
problèmes pour les élections
présidentielles suivantes
et c'est une vraie question est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui
on peut
le cas échéant interdire un réseau
social ou est-ce que de toute façon
aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux sont les
plus forts et vous pouvez pas
réguler dans une très faible mesure et
en tout cas pas interdire même si au
bout de des courriez des choses
épouvantables sauf un coup politique
voilà est-ce que les plateformes sont
devenus aujourd'hui plus fortes que les
États ou pas
je reconnais que c'est de la politique
fiction
dans ce domaine en disant d'abord en
guise d'introduction que le la question
qui se pose aux États-Unis évidemment
c'est que quand vous avez un produit qui
fait 12 milliards en tout cas l'année
dernière 12 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires vous avez quand même envie
quelqu'un a envie de le reprendre ou de
racheter et c'était un peu ce que Trump
avait essayé de faire dans sa première
version alors ça pas forcément été bien
bien
organisé et depuis effectivement on est
dans une question c'est le est-ce que la
Chine accepte de vendre
ce produit ou est-ce que on le tout
simplement on interdit alors
moi personnellement j'ai toujours été en
faveur d'une
réciprocité j'ai toujours pensé que
c'est d'ailleurs c'est un problème qu'on
a eu également avec une autre
un autre un autre média qui était un
média russe que vous connaissez bien RT
qui se dit quand on se dit si Poutine
ferme les médias est-ce que nous en
Europe on doit aussi
fermer sur décision administratives les
médias et
quel en est-il donc c'est vrai que c'est
un dilemme et aujourd'hui
l'angle qui semble se enfin d'après de
ce que je vois aux États-Unis c'est de
revenir sur cette question de la de la
concentration des médias et de la du
fait que on a on offre à la Chine une
porte de sortie alors là vous avez
absolument raison c'est que Tik Tok est
quand même prisé par ce qu'on appelle la
génération Z ou les ou les très jeunes
donc potentiellement aussi les futurs
électeurs de de Biden alors que côté
républicain on a plutôt tendance à être
ok avec une potentielle interdiction de
Tik Tok donc ça pose évidemment un
politique c'est à dire un vilain
poétique qui se posera aussi
possiblement en Europe si on prend sa
décision mais à la différence peut-être
des États-Unis c'est que si c'est
l'Europe qu'il le fait ce sera pas
forcément un pays ou qui en aura assez
belle les conséquences donc c'est un
vrai dilemme et je pense qu'on a
c'est pour ça en tout cas c'est mon
interprétation c'est pour ça que que
très agressif en ce moment sur les
questions d'accès aux puces d'accès
aux technologies essentielles parce
qu'on est probablement dans un bras de
fer entre les deux pays
Tik Tok n'est qu'un des éléments de ce
bras de fer
il y a la question évidemment Taïwan qui
est le principal producteur de puces
comme vous le savez un petit peu la
Corée un petit peu le Japon mais c'est
essentiellement Taïwan donc on est sur
un design une vision assez
géopolitique assez large et ce qui moi
me questionne c'est évidemment quelle
est la position de l'Europe par rapport
à ça parce que on peut poser la question
évidemment de savoir si Tik Tok doit
être interdit en Europe pour des raisons
on va dire des principales raisons qu'on
a indiqué mais qu'est-ce que l'Europe a
retiré dans ce jeu puisque derrière
évidemment c'est négociations il y a des
compromis qui vont être faits entre les
États-Unis entre la Chine et donc la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
est-ce que l'Europe va faire partie de
ces compromis ou pas
quels sont les avantages que nous
intervenons ou est-ce que l'on est
simplement un peu les damons de la farce
et qu'on se retrouve avec une décision
qui pourrait être triste parce que je
suis quasiment sûr que si les États-Unis
en arrivaient à interdire Tik Tok je
pense que l'Europe aurait une position
similaire je tiens rappelé que l'Inde
l'a déjà fait que d'autres pays
regardent ça avec avec intérêt donc
effectivement je reste en la politique
fiction
s'il y a une négociation et donc c'est
une bataille d'intérêts
quels sont les intérêts quels sont nos
leviers et je pense que d'un palu
européen on aurait aussi intérêt à
identifier notamment avec ARN notamment
avec ASML avec un ensemble d'entreprise
qui font que cet écosystème numérique ne
peut pas exister sans nous en tout cas
pour une partie d'entre elles et puis en
tant que marché extrêmement rentable
d'utilisateurs et donc voilà donc je
dirais que la question de l'interdiction
ne peut pas être vu sans aborder cette
vision globale en tout cas c'est ce que
je crois et que simplement dire on va
faire net Tik Tok parce que c'est ce
qu'il faut faire c'est la vision morale
je n'y crois pas je pense que derrière
il y a des tractations il y a des
négociations mais comme vous le savez
bien et comme
vous savez prendre mieux que moi dans
toutes ces négociations il y a toujours
des tractations et des choses que l'on
souhaite ou ne souhaite pas avoir c'est
moins clair pour moi ce que l'Europe
peut tirer ou souhaite obtenir de ce
genre de tractations
j'en aurais bien eu mais il faut qu'on
soit raisonnable du fait des questions
au Gouvernement
nous allons donner le plus de
concentration possible nous aussi bah
écoutez c'est un regret parce que je
pense qu'on aurait pu creuser encore un
peu mais nous avons aussi la possibilité
de vous adresser des questions
complémentaires dans le cadre de la
commission d'enquête en tout cas nous
vous remercions beaucoup de votre
éclairage qui ouvre aussi mais c'est ça
les propos intelligents encore plus de
questions que celles auxquelles vous
avez vous avez répondu merci infiniment
merci